for many people the holiday season can
be a time when loneliness hits hard a
recent Sigma study reveals loneliness is
that epidemic levels nationwide nearly
half of Americans report feeling alone
sometimes are always researchers say
suffering through it can be as lethal as
smoking 15 cigarettes a day Alex Wagner
spoke with a group of people who at one
point described themselves as lonely
Alex good morning good morning guys
being lonely for the record is not the
same as being alone in fact many of the
people I spoke to are in relationships
they have kids and they have families
this is a diverse group ranging from a
25 year old social-media influencer to a
90 year old widow complete strangers who
all connect on one thing I'm typically
not the lonely type I'm usually like the
life of the party I'm usually like super
happy this one day I was like in my room
and I was like I really like this dark
cloud over me you know I just don't want
to get up I don't want to get up I don't
want to breathe I don't want to eat I
don't want to do anything and you know
I've never felt like that before
everybody's experience with loneliness
is different right each of one of you
has different stories they're different
triggers for the loneliness different
family dynamics at least you lost your
job yes Lord all my life and losing that
social connection it's it's very
isolating Aveline you lost your husband
who is your lifetime partner can you
tell us a little bit about how you've
dealt with that and how it's made you
feel so after 66 years of marriage you
went to sleep one day and didn't wake up
and and I was all alone I had never
really been without him it was
particularly bad at night you know we
slept at a double bed and I would put my
foot out and there was nobody there the
aging process can also be lonely too in
a way
can it I'm still active I'm still
reading I don't have problems walking
and Felicia you became a mom and
motherhood is a gift at the blessing
it's a beautiful
but it also can be lonely in can't it it
can I have two faces you know I have my
my social face and then I have my mom
face and for my kids I don't want to cry
I don't want to express any sadness you
know so I'm like smiling but it's
plastered on my face because I'm like
this isn't real people think you're a
stay-at-home mom girl you're doing yoga
you're going through the mom you're
making passionate love all night like
life is lit and it's like no actually
I'm so busy that I don't know who I am
all of you moms are nodding in agreement
I had severe loneliness and I think
balancing being a new mom and trying to
find myself what I did is I literally
sat on my couch and I did a post and I
just was completely transparent with my
followers and I said if you guys are
willing let's meet up in Central Park
have a little mama meet up somewhere
single summer divorce I'm a co-parenting
but it was great to see that all our
issues transcend when we talk about
connectivity in this day and age there's
an expectation that it will feed us the
the world of social media is enough to
sustain us I think the irony of social
media is a it was intended to connect us
but I really feel like it disconnects us
in a way you know on social media you
don't put out many vulnerable sides to
you you this all my life is perfect
everything is going great in my life you
put filters on your life you put
different things on your life to make
your life look really great and in that
process I feel that maybe you're not
totally being honest as yourself you
know and honest with other people you
have you know X amount of followers and
like that's great but like you know how
many are those people are really care
about you or want to know what you're
doing it's and that's always the tough
part in that sense I feel I feel the
Facebook well it's can be wonderful it
is also horrible why the flip side of it
is when it's Thanksgiving okay and I'm
single and alone and you look on
Facebook and everyone's with their
family and their children and their
grandchildren or sitting around the
table isn't this wonderful and
it just makes you feel horrible doctor
wench when we talk about loneliness it's
not just people feeling bad there are
significant and very real health risks
that are associated with this very much
so loneliness now is a greater public
health concern then obesity and smoking
combined people don't think of
loneliness as a problem or something
they might they think well I'm saying
they don't identify they're not honest
but it's absolute work you have to take
it seriously what helps you know how do
you get through times that are tough I
find activity that you like to do with
others okay like for me it's bowling
okay
I've been boiling for 30 years so that
so I feel that you have to find a happy
that you like to do and try to do it
with other people
okay I think you just have to reach out
every once in a while you can't expect
everybody to come to you oh grandma how
are you feeling you know I'd rather call
Jack and say hey what's going on with
the latest girlfriend I think first and
foremost you have to admit to yourself
that you're alone I think it's safe to
say that that I was lonely but I did see
a side of me that was very afraid of
coming out with it because I was afraid
of being judged a lot more people are
willing to help than you think having
someone show up like when they feel that
you need that is is really big for me
that's I mean if there's a message for
this holiday season it's knock on a door
or make a phone call stay in touch is it
helpful to talk with other people to
know that other people feel this the
same way that you do and that you
nothing you don't have to feel so much
shame about it I think that we are here
and we're all unique and all these
situations are different and it is
important to to shed awareness because
someone is sitting on the other end of
the screen and they they're like they
can't relate to me but maybe they can
relate to you I think it's great because
we all acknowledge the others like it
helps you to acknowledge everyone else
is loneliness regardless if it doesn't
mirror yours
doctors say being proactive is a way to
combat loneliness start connecting or
reconnecting with people even if it is
just a few you can rely on breaking the
stigma and increasing awareness helps to
fight loneliness and speaking out is the
first step you will discover that
loneliness is a lot more
and then we realized wow I love that
idea of Alex that you can be alone even
with your even if you're a people and
also it's up to us right we should knock
on that elderly neighbors door that
person who's newly single I like I
donate a connection to yes they did